well it looks like donald trump's days
as the 45th president of the united
states and now
finally numbered after weeks of fierce
resistance
trump has told officials to cooperate in
the transition of power
to president-elect joe biden
but he apparently remains determined to
make life as difficult as possible for
his successor
while biden has been working on the
final details of his new government team
trump has been issuing warnings to iran
and preparing to
order a far-reaching troop withdrawal
from afghanistan
on to the point we therefore ask trump's
last days in office lame duck
or raging bull
[Music]
well thanks very much indeed for joining
us and my guests here in the studio are
susanna koble
foreign correspondent for spiegel
magazine who says trump has had a
devastating impact on america's standing
as a reliable global leader
the old america no longer exists
also with us eric kirschbaum a freelance
journalist who writes for the la times
and says
trump's power is fading by the day but
his failure to ensure a smooth
transition to biden
has become a real threat to national
security
and a very warm welcome too to alif
atola nijad a german
iranian political scientist with the
afro middle east centre in johannesburg
and ali argues that overt military
adventurism against iranian interests
may prove too
costly even for donald trump so covert
operations
are more likely yeah thank you all three
for being here today first question eric
donald trump's former
national security adviser john bolton
says the big question
is how much damage trump can still do
before the january the 20th inauguration
and you think he might do quite a bit of
damage i thought the biggest threat to
national security was not
giving biden's team the secret the
the intelligence reports that need to be
given to the new president and not
cooperating with the new team that's a
that's a risk here in this interim
period of the
incoming president not being up to speed
this is something obama did for trump
this is something that bush did for
obama
it's something that's always done in
america we've never seen a situation
like this where the president
is not cooperating with the incoming
team that's hopefully going to be
changing now we've seen some small
developments this week and hopefully
that i'll get better
that's the big problem for national
security susana what do you say on that
question about the
the threat to national security the
threat of national social security
uh is is most likely as mr krishna just
laid out but
what he still can do is damage to to
to to um countries where uh the
americans have a
have a big leverage and a huge impact
like for instance in afghanistan like
uh um uh for instance i i heard
that he still tries to convince pakistan
to um to
give up the resistance against israel so
he still does whatever he can
to leave his heritage and that biden has
to deal with it
what do they well i think he's also i
mean
uh you know trying to address two uh
constituents or
two uh circles of friends or supporters
one is the regional allies of trump
uh israel saudi arabia most notably who
fear
that with the biden presidency there
might be another iran policy and which
would
you know tremendously decrease the
pressure on iran so they're trying to
you know
figure something out to do in this
interim period
another one is appealing to a social
constituency in the united states
and uh when it comes to the troop
withdrawal in afghanistan so
this is going going to go down
well with them so um but at the end of
the day we're going to see
which which of those developments going
to materialize or not
okay yeah i mean trump has promised his
voters
he's going to bring the soldiers back
home he's going to end these endless
wars
and he's wanted to do more in
afghanistan all along he had to fire his
last defense minister a week or two ago
who didn't want to withdraw the troops
um this is something that trump
supporters want this is something a lot
of american veterans want i think
20 million americans have served in
these last wars the last two decades and
there's a strong sentiment
hey we lost there's no point let's get
out of there
just tell me again about the perspective
of the people of iran is it
can you generalize about you know which
direction they lean in biden or trump
well uh this is a you know there is a
controversy in iran i think
i mean of course i mean trump don't
doesn't have
uh any kind of fans or supporters among
iranians because of its anti-democratic
credentials so people are you know are
not
do do not have any illusions that this
is a kind of democratic president they
can rely upon and pin their hopes
on but there is a controversy among
iranians
uh you know one side says that actually
the maximum pressure strategy with the
economic sanctions on the regime has
been quite
uh important because it has been
weakening the regime
so this is something that you know a lot
of iranians are critical of the regime
would welcome
uh on the other hand uh and and and in
in this week actually they they fear
that biden might
opt for an appeasement a quesadilla
appeasement policy on iran
when sanctions would be eased and uh
cash would
would return to the to the leadership in
iran
on the other hand there are others who
argue that state society power relations
have
uh you know developed negatively and
because
with the sanctions also civil society is
actually weakened and i think this
controversy is going to continue
susana you are feverishly writing down
notes
um i mean when it comes to iran
obviously i mean the people
of iran they don't they don't mind
whether this the the situation they are
living in will be changed by
by a new uprise or by negotiations or
anything they need to have
something changed in their country i
mean they're absolutely
there question now is that they need
something changed and this is for
many parts of the world so what role can
america play in this what is what is
going to change with joe biden and his
now newly announced team
coming into office well biden has sent
signals that he wants to reopen the
return to the deal um who knows there's
an election coming up in iran but one
thing i like about iran that's important
not to forget is
hezbollah for four years ago was a real
problem hezbollah has been
starved of resources now because of the
sanctions the sanctions that are
perhaps popular among ordinary iranians
are also
reducing terrorism the threat of
terrorism thanks to what trump did there
that's only that's only one of the
effects actually really i mean
let's let's let's be fair hezbollah also
has a problem because you have an it's a
crisis in lebanon which actually brought
everything
everything down and also hezbollah and
they are just a part of that society
certainly the resources are are are cut
back
uh iran doesn't have the money to be to
be active everywhere they are in yemen
they are in
in syria they are in in in lebanon but
at the end of the day it's a combination
of a couple of things so it didn't work
out hundred percent
and i i wouldn't i wouldn't like to to
to
uh to say that okay let's just rewind
for a moment the
the incumbent president of the united
states of america is still donald trump
and it seems that he is slowly accepting
that he can't stay in the white house
indefinitely so the question is will it
be
by the front door or by the back door
that he leaves and will it be with a
bang or a whimper donald trump has
half-heartedly and
indirectly admitted defeat on twitter
four weeks after the election
but the incumbent president remains in a
solemn mood
judicial challenges to the election
result have no prospects of success
trump is only half-heartedly completing
mandatory tasks
such as the virtual g20 summit after a
while he cut the signal
and went to play golf he seems to be
spending more time at the golf course
than the white house
in one of his few public appearances
trump seemed so uninspired
that even his personal broadcaster fox
news ended the live broadcast
it is getting lonely for the most
powerful man in the world
has donald trump given up
that still is the question has he given
up he's got another couple of
weeks to work with what should we expect
from those couple of weeks i mean he's a
little he looked at the g20 very washed
out but we have uh we have the
impression that he still has a lot of
sort of dark
intent well i mean he's certainly
struggling
uh as someone as i alluded to earlier
who doesn't believe in really in
democratic institutions and processes so
he has he had a tough time and now
uh you know um i think he's you know
trying to prepare
or to satisfy his supporters
domestically and internationally
by some of the moves that we're talking
about uh but we have to see
whether all those move gonna move is
gonna materialize
and um and this is also probably in view
of his
re you know uh prop or eventual or
probable
or like or unlikely whatever rerun in
2024
so to keep the uh the support of
regional allies
and also to keep the support of the
social constituencies that he has in the
country
when you talk about moves being made
you're talking i
i assume about diplomacy and i'm just
wondering susanna you see
you indicated at the top of your show of
the show in your statement
that the old america is no longer
the america that was there yeah it's a
different america now
are you talking there about diplomacy
has america lost its
i think it's both america america has
first of all lost lost its credibility
people don't know what to expect from
this america any longer
and uh and and and secondly suddenly uh
trump
left a mark which will will will not go
unnoticed for the for for the
for the next years and decades so he has
really changed the face of america and
america has changed its
focus i mean the middle east is and
europe
is not is not their first priority any
longer so this has begun already in
terms of right now yes it has yeah
so so so so the end of pacific uh area
is
is or region is actually they are their
their um
focus on now and we have to live with
the with the repercussions
and trump was just an extreme um
uh an extreme um way to
to to to present this to us to us
and joe biden says america is back what
does it mean where did you get the
confidence from well i wouldn't be as
gloomy and depressed as the others here
i mean i think uh the united states is a
leader will be a leader and i think
that's one of the reasons biden wanted
to run for president he wanted to
help restore the united states tradition
the reputation the united states has
just being a leader and he likes working
with alliances he likes working with
partners he gave a very important speech
last year at the munich security
conference
talking about alliances and i think
biden will be a lot like
previous american republican and
democratic presidents i think trump will
be the aberration
when we look back at this period in
history diplomacy is back
says biden definitely i mean look at his
choice for foreign secretary of state i
mean this is somebody who works
who's lived a lot of his life in europe
and is realizes the importance of
realizes the values of these relations
and alliances and biden says himself the
united states is stronger
with its partners this is a new a new
sound a new tone
coming from washington i think the last
four years have hardened a lot of people
in europe they think
horrible things about the united states
but it worked the institutions worked
democracy worked and now we have
a new president after just four years of
donald trump
a major rebuilding job has just begun
it's already underway taratara do you
buy into it
well i mean as much as you know
trump tried to revert reverse everything
obama
did uh biden is going to do the same
when it comes to trump's policies
um yet we're not going to to see
a sea change on all conceivable levels
some of the things that trump did
were preceding him uh the you know the
disagreements over
the role of european partners in nato
the
issue with china and also um
i mean biden is true that biden has
decades of
you know experience in the foreign
policy establishment but realities in
the ground in release have
dramatically changed since a decade ago
we have entered a process where you know
some people call it a long-term
revolutionary process
where there's a lot of you know
dissatisfaction uprisings all over the
place so this is there are changing
realities on the ground
and there are probably also different
expectations from the united states uh
so
um the challenges are extreme but
uh surely he can mend
transatlantic relations there is also an
appetite for that here in europe
okay when you talk about changes on the
ground the part of the world we're
talking about is the one that goes from
the middle east through
iran right over to afghanistan donald
trump has had
quite a an impact there let's have a
look at where things stand for the time
being and then we'll talk more about
those revolutionary pushes
in afghanistan and iraq the old
president is creating facts before the
new one is sworn in
trump will withdraw 2 000 u.s soldiers
from hindu kush
alone by mid-january u.s allies are
outraged
because without american air support
their deployments on the ground could
become
suicide missions the taliban could
regain
power and afghanistan could once again
become a haven
of terrorism but trump's policies have
many supporters in the rich countries of
the middle east
bahrain and the united arab emirates
have established diplomatic relations
with israel
with the help of u.s mediation saudi
arabia may be the next to do so
the palestinians and their interests
however have been completely ignored by
trump
trump's hostility towards iran is
legendary
after he terminated the iran nuclear
deal sanctions and threats against
tehran followed
even an airstrike on iran under trump
cannot be ruled out
will trump's foreign policy become a
security risk
in the final days of his term in office
susanna is there a biden doctrine
as far as i can see there is a doctrine
that he wants to to heal
uh the wounds that that trump has uh
um has created the doctrine is certainly
to
um to reunite with the with the allies
but uh the us is not an altruism
altruistic uh um country it's a it's
it's a country driven by interests so
finally
what we see is a nicer um
a nicer approach but good intentions
good intentions good intentions are back
good intentions are back which is a good
thing which is a great thing and
at the same time the interests
will stay the same i mean there is there
is much more
room for negotiations now which is
wonderful and people who
know their job and know have have their
expertise
uh obviously having uh an opportunity to
be heard which has not been the case
in the last four years or only very
rarely has been uh
the case so i think that's definitely an
undocumented but but what we will see
is is is not the the america um
um that we have seen five years ago or
which we have known five years ago under
under obama obama's america
yeah uh tell me about the mood the mood
on the streets in iran
and how that you know this diplomatic
this new would-be new diplomatic
approach on high
and the people down on the streets
getting more and more angry and
impoverished in iran
how does that knit together well um
i mean i think i mean first of all it's
important to point out how the iranian
leadership also thinks about this
question and they've
been fearing the ramifications of
trump's maximum maximum pressure
strategy because of the
economic uh you know economic sanctions
that were quite onerous
on the regime answers there was a lot of
hopes pinned on the biden administration
so from the leadership side it's quite
clear
from from the societal level as i've
alluded to earlier there are different
estimations on uh on on on the benefits
of sanctions and and uh some sections
might be in favor of sanctions but there
are other important sections in
uh sections of the population in iran
who fear
the uh you know the ramifications of
economic sanctions on
on the general population but be it as
it may the general feeling
uh for a few years now at least in iran
is that they
identify the policies of their own
government to be the most
important factor in their own fate and
for their own so um
so foreign forces although they have a
very important
uh you know impact upon iran be it
by action or by inaction be it the
united states or europe
will have a continuing impact but um
there are no more let's say there are no
more illusions that there is a
foreign savior although uh the domestic
situation in iran that is also not
really you know uh filled with hope uh
pushes some people
to think about a foreign savior but i
think also trump didn't prove to be
uh you know aiding uh iranian uh
democracy
yeah eric so the
the biden administration is promising to
take a a radically different approach
and when you uh i just wonder
i'd like to take you know uh something
like uh the american
assurance that uh or recognition of
jerusalem as the as the capital of
israel is that the kind of
uh policy that joe biden might reverse
where are we expecting reverses no i
don't think um
the american will change their policy
with the cap with the embassy in
jerusalem and the recognition of the
capital um bite or uh
trump is hugely popular in israel he's
been very pro-israel from the beginning
as we as we saw another thing
he's done in the middle east that's
important that's also written about in
the u.s
press a lot is the the um the peace with
uae and possibly saudi arabia this is
something that's getting a lot of
attention or got a lot of attention the
u.s
also from from um liberal columnists who
were praising trump saying
in other times he'd be nominated for the
nobel peace prize and i know in germany
trump is not that popular and i was
really interested to see the media
hardly wrote about that but
there were quite a few liberal
journalists here in germany as well yeah
but i mean in germany
if that had been obama it would have
been a lot different story i think so
you see
how unfair sometimes the the the the
media is towards trump especially in
europe
and that was a pretty big important
breakthrough and i think that's
something a legacy that will trump will
be remembered for
um the the breakthrough with uae and
saudi arabia
well i would be actually more cautious
because what actually happened
uh under trump's watch is in
officializing
of some of america's policies and
realities in the region that were there
you know so there was cooperation
between all those states
uh you know more covertly than overtly
and now it is officialized
plus the fact that none of those regimes
are you know democratic they're you know
very authoritarian regimes
and they by no account can you know
represent
the arab populations and their
aspirations in the region so
um so this is you know this is not a
positive development per se
that there is now a you know peace deal
between bahrain
saudi arabia and the uae and israel this
is not something
you know that is going to lead
necessarily to a positive development
for the region and also to positive
outcomes for
the populations of the region so there
is a lot of uh you know
euphoria about what was happening
although
i think it's much of that euphoria is
misleading it's also not the end of the
story i would say i mean for instance i
mean you you can
you can befriend uh uh the
the uae but at the end of the day uh the
problem is not solved with the
palestinians so
you cannot ignore it i mean you cannot
put it to the to the history boxes they
solved no it's not solved i mean the
palestinian issue is still there
it's considered as failed now i mean
and uh you have huge frustrations in the
palestinian
communities and just look to jordan for
instance i mean they take
they they have taken like millions of
palestinians
and where shall they go actually they
just they just
leave the problem in the region and give
it back to people who can deal with it
and that's not what what a world power
or the superpower should do they should
actually
uh uh try to to balance and they try
should try to um to to heal what
what what this um what this uh
story of in in in the history has has
done to
to to those people of the palestinians
for instance a general question because
we don't have much time and i'm just
interested in the in the sort of the
philosophy of all this
biden has said he won't just try to
repair diplomacy
he'll try to reimagine diplomacy that i
thought was an interesting juncture in
his his policy foreign policy address
just a couple of days ago and i but
what does that mean reimagine diplomacy
who's going to who's the quickest
as much as i think that what trump did
with all those states in the region is a
pr stunt
um the same could be applied to what
just you know what you just quoted from
biden i mean
it would be very desirable if the united
states would go for some creative
diplomacy in various some of the you
know very difficult spots of
uh your theories of conflict in the
region
but uh i'm actually not sure what he's
really meaning uh by that
what might it mean in concrete terms
as far as relations between washington
and nato and europe and germany go
um with nato i think it's pretty clear i
think the united states
um under biden just like under trump and
obama wants germany and
the nato allies in europe to do more for
their own security i think that's
very clear all the comments we've seen
have been clear that germany needs to do
more
um some parties in germany want to do
more some don't
but this idea about reimagining
diplomacy i mean biden's
main challenge and something he's
talking about aside from climate is is
covet 19 and i think that's going to be
his number one priority and i think he'd
like to see the world working together
maybe that's what he's talking about
seeing countries working together as
we're seeing with the vaccines that are
coming out these are cooperations taking
place
that's probably where biden is hoping
for the biggest breakthroughs as quickly
as possible with the coronavirus
i mean if you if you if you want to
reinvent
diplomacy you can you should not talk to
one side
only i mean if we spoke about this huge
success which is a success
that you um normalize relations
with israel israel but if it's actually
if you actually built
an alliance against a co
a common enemy and this is actually the
target of this and this is the only
thing
everybody can agree on that's not really
a diplomacy which is very fruitful in
the issue naive
is joe biden naive here no he's
certainly not naive
and he has to deal with that i mean it's
it's progress in some way but you also
have to address the other issues which
have not been addressed by
by by trump he just tried to to dry out
and to
suffocate uh iran which is actually
quite unlikely that it really succeeds
trump's last days in office lame duck or
raging bull that was the question we
asked at the beginning of the show
what's your answer early lame duck or
raging bull
well i think there is no easy answer to
this and i don't know what is
what is going to happen but um we're
going to see
some uh some acts that might be symbolic
and and that he wants to address uh you
know his supporters
hitherto and he wants to guarantee that
they will continue to do so in the next
few years
lame duck or raging bull i think it'll
be more lame duck could be playing more
golf and he'll keep pardoning prisoners
and people who've helped him
but i think playing golf is actually a
good thing the more he plays golf the
less damage
he can perhaps do the final word
i i hope as well that he has he can
improve his handicap but
but at the same time we will see more
trumps to come
more trump's to come thank you very much
for joining us here on to the point this
week that's an interesting place to
finish i hope we've given you plenty of
food for thought if we have
goodbye and choose come back
[Music]
you